amúgy a a a hangfelismerő funkcióját
nagyon ajánlom mindenkinek nagyon jó még
a magyar nyelven is nagyon jó
hangfelismerő funkciója van vagy ez a a
text to speech bocsos speech to text
vagyis hogy a szöveget a az a beszélt
szöveget írott szöveggé alakítja át ezek
hihetetlenül hatékonnyá teszik a az én
munkámat is vagyis hogy rengeteg dolgot
diktálok le neki miközben sétálgatok a
parkba és a végén aztán azt kérem hogy
foglald össze azt amit mondtam és ez már
ez a desztilációs folyamat rengeteget
segít abban hogy megértsem hogy
valójában mit is mondtam mert ha ha a
kreatív elmémet szabadjára engedem akkor
nem egy annyira strukturált dolog az
amit mondok hanem egy picit úgy
össz-evissza van és akkor utána azzal az
a a tudás kontextussal amit már a a a
felépítettem a a beszélgetés során egy
csomó mindent lehet kezdeni